Secretary of State Rex Tillerson says
president Trump's Afghanistan strategy
may lead to something other than total
victory Tillerson said yesterday that
the goal is to get the Taliban to the
negotiating table I think the president
was clear this entire effort is intended
to put pressure on the Taliban to have
the Taliban understand you will not win
a battlefield victory we may not win one
but neither will you
and so at some point we have to come to
the negotiating table and find a way to
bring this to an end Afghanistan's
president said a planned influx of US
troops will help enhance Afghan air
power our Charlie d'Agata is in Kabul to
show us how Americans are helping fight
the Taliban from the sky charlie good
morning well good morning when Afghan
President Ashraf Ghani thanked President
Trump and the American people for their
continued support here this week the
first thing he mentioned was the
importance of the development of the
Afghan Air Force well we got the rare
opportunity to watch American pilots
training pilots hear how to wage war
over Afghanistan's not-so-friendly skies
it may not look like a modern aircraft
[Music]
and again the Afghan military's long
fight against the Taliban could hardly
be described as a modern war what
they're missing a brigadier general
Philip Stewart says it just might break
the stalemate here this is a country
that screens out for air power it
doesn't have a whole lot of roads
it's mountainous and that terrain suits
the new Afghan fighter division which
consists of 12 American built a 29
planes and about two dozen MD 530 attack
helicopters capable of delivering a full
payload heavy machine guns and guided
missiles
u.s. combat pilot Lieutenant Colonel
Johnny green is in charge of handling
Afghanistan's top guns all the
communication is on them the guy on the
ground here's the target speaking to the
pilot in the cockpit all in their own
language that is all on them so is the
maintenance because the a29 uses the
same kind of engine found in planes like
Cessnas they're easy to fix it says
something about the security situation
here that pilots don't want to be
identified but he said it's the Taliban
who have new reasons to be fearful at
the first they were like laughing at
this it's it's like a this is the world
world styled world he said that was
until they found themselves on the
receiving end of one in combat
[Applause]
after that they they said we should hide
so now they hide when yeah yeah hi yes
they're also capable of dropping
laser-guided 500-pound bombs which makes
them both cheap and deadly an aircraft
like this is not gonna hold its own
against a an air force like the Russians
or China sure it's not designed to is
there a need to have advanced aircraft
no not in this theater you know this
since the Afghan Air Force just fine so
what makes it a pretty unfair fight we
hope so in our in our favor right so
that's that's the desire and it's a
mission on fast-forward Afghan pilots
come right out of us training and
straight into combat with the Taliban
gaining ground the only advantage
they've gotten is above it just
yesterday US Air Force officials said
they are not only examining new ways to
expand the training of the Afghan Air
Force but ramping up US air power and
American air strikes in light of the new
military strategy here Gail thank you
Charlie d'Agata reporting from Kabul